[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans auditions
publiques l'émission politique commune à
LCP et Public Sénat une invitée ce soir
pendant une heure toutes les questions
évidemment qui constituent l'actualité
brûlante parce que ce sera peut-être la
terre d'eder cette semaine sera-t-elle
la dernière du parcours parlementaire de
la réforme des retraites pas impossible
qu'il y ait un vote cette semaine c'est
le rêve du gouvernement il faudrait pour
cela passer avec succès le cap de la
commission mixte paritaire et obtenir
une majorité Emmanuel Macron
osera-t-il prendre le risque ou
préférera-t-il assurer avec le 49-3 tout
peut donc se jouer dans cette assemblée
jeudi après-midi bonjour ma petite panot
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être notre
patronne des députés les filles une des
porte-paroles du groupe sur cette
réforme vous êtes très souvent intervenu
sur la fond le gouvernement ira chercher
des députés avec les dents c'est ce
qu'on a compris des prises de parole des
ministres ces dernières heures avec les
pour la faire voter et croyez-vous ce
serait une victoire pour le gouvernement
une défaite pour la gauche quelle sera
la suite du mouvement il faut trouver
une porte de sortie par la force si
besoin c'est ce qu'a dit votre leader
Jean-Luc Mélenchon samedi qu'est-ce que
cela veut dire on attend vos
explications Brigitte boucher et Tamet
reviendront sur les deux journées
décisives mercredi et jeudi à
l'Assemblée pourrez-vous peser sur ces
deux journées Yves trèsart lui évoquera
les débats autour de votre stratégie
politique
Vincent vous posera des questions
d'actualité vous avez accepté en faisant
merci le débat avec Charles système soul
député Renaissance deux sujets il
évoquera deux sujets avec vous d'abord
la loi qui prévoit de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires il est arrivé
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée et la loi sur
le redécoupage des régions pour
commencer ma petite pano je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé il y a
quelques minutes ou à peine une Emmanuel
Macron qui est d'une certaine façon
descendue dans l'arène il se tenait un
peu en réserve et il a transmis un
message sur la réforme des retraites à
sa majorité qu'on va vous lire cette
réforme est une nécessité absolue pour
le financement de nos retraites et la
solidité du pays nous avons une majorité
solide on doit porter ce discours et
faire appel à la responsabilité des
oppositions qui pourraient voter la
réforme d'abord Emmanuel Macron qui
prend position 48 heures avant un vote
qui peut changer la donne ça vous
surprend il était pas trop tôt parce que
vous avez raison Emmanuel Macron qui est
responsable du chaos qui est
actuellement dans le pays était en
quelque sorte en train de se cacher
derrière son gouvernement ces derniers
mois on était intervenus que la semaine
dernière pour répondre au syndicat et à
l'Inter syndical qui demandait un
rendez-vous pour leur dire qu'il ne
verrait pas l'Inter syndical et
finalement on est face à Emmanuel Macron
pour qui la démocratie ne suffit plus
alors il piétine le parle il refuse de
voir l'Inter syndical je rappelle que
les syndicats eux aussi sont élus ils
refusent de voir des manifestations dans
lesquelles il y a 3,5 millions de
personnes et donc je crois que là il est
obligé en quelque sorte de s'exprimer
parce que on sent une certaine fébrilité
chez le pouvoir parce que ce que vous
avez dit dès le début est un mensonge le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites le
dit nous n'avons pas besoin de cette
réforme et lorsque l'on parle d'un
déficit imaginaire qui arriverait et
bien nous avons par des milliers
d'amendements proposer nous la nupesse
de le combler et de la même non
seulement pour sauvegarder ce système à
62 ans mais même pour aller à la
retraite à 60 ans moi je n'ai rien dit
j'ai cité le message d'Emmanuel Macron à
celui-ci effectivement voilà qui parle
d'une nécessité absolue pour le
financement du système de retraite vous
dites il est fébrile il est sur la
défensive il prend c'est ce que vous
comprenez il a besoin de s'adresser
directement à la majorité et aux
oppositions puisque il fait appel à la
responsabilité qui je pourrais des
oppositions qui pourraient voter la
réforme il s'adresse à qui alors il
s'adresse d'abord au députés Renaissance
mais aussi modem et horizon vous avez
entendu certains parlementaires qui ont
d'ores et déjà dit malgré des menaces
d'exclusion qu'il ne voteraient pas
cette réforme je pense notamment à
barbara Pompili mais à d'autres qui sont
en train de distinguer les oppositions
qui pourronter cette réforme après
évidemment il parle au LR enfin il a
tout essayé avec les LR il les a menacé
de dissolution pour que ils aient peur
et qu'ils puissent arrêter avec cela et
donc il essaye en quelque sorte de
constituer une majorité pour ce texte
mais vous comprenez est-ce qu'il peut y
arrivera et bien et bien c'est une bonne
question parce que chacun des députés
est quand même sous pression populaire
extrêmement forte lorsque vous avez 3,5
millions de manifestants cela veut dire
quand
l'année dernière mardi 7 mars cela veut
dire que dans chacune des
circonscriptions des députés il y a
parfois 10000 parfois 50000 parfois des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
manifestent et je vous assure que en
tant que député je pense qu'ils vont
poser se poser trois fois la question
avant d'appuyer sur tel ou tel bouton
qui manifestent et qui pourraient vous
reprocher de voter cette rétention alors
nous sommes notre argument alors non il
y en a beaucoup nous sommes tous des
représentants du peuple je pense que y
compris les LR ils sont sensibles
ensuite nous sommes des parlementaires
et que y compris tous les députés
peuvent être sensibles au fait que le
Parlement a été complètement écrasé dans
cette période ça c'est la deuxième des
choses et la troisième chose c'est que
ne soyons pas dupe s'ils ont le moindre
doute sur le vote alors ils utiliseront
le 49-3 une nouvelle fois ça sera la
centième utilisation du 49 sur 3 dans la
Cinquième République et de nouveau un
outil antidémocratique à la Cinquième
République utilisée pour passer en force
vous parlez des doutes est-ce que vous
avez des doutes vous Mathilde panneau
sur le fait qu'Emmanuel Macron pourra
retirer son texte non je moi je
manifeste toutes les semaines depuis
maintenant le 17 janvier
pour exiger qu'Emmanuel Macron aux côtés
de 80% des Français aux côtés de 93% des
actifs aux côtés de l'Inter syndical uni
et de la nupes unie nous demandons
toutes et tous qu'il retire son texte il
le fera est-ce que vous pensez qu'il le
fera et bien et bien je dis à Emmanuel
Macron qu'il faut avoir parfois du
courage en politique et que le courage
en politique ce n'est pas de gouverner
contre le peuple et donc s'il continue
de passer en force tel qu'il est en
train de le faire nous aurons des
séquelles très graves dans notre pays et
si vous me permettez je veux juste dire
un mot d'alerte parce que moi j'ai une
énorme inquiétude quand j'entends un
proche du président un conseiller du
président dire dans des journaux qu'il
faudrait un mort Paris à feu ou un
attentat pour arrêter 16 pour arrêter
cette réforme des retraites
ces cité tel quel dans un journal un
proche du président de la République
voilà vous opinez donc vous l'avez lui
aussi qui dit le président Macron
pourrait reculer s'il y aurait un mort
un attentat ou Paris à feu je le dis
c'est un jeu extrêmement dangereux
que de considérer que la démocratie en
temps normal ne peut pas en quelque
sorte opérer et donc il faudrait des
événements extraordinaires avec en plus
de la violence pour que le président
ne le souhaite pas et la question lui
poser dans quelles circonstances
Emmanuel Macron pourrait reculer et se
proche répond en effet s'il y avait un
drame un drame effectivement il serait
là obligé de reculer et là vous trouvez
que seul
d'évoquer cela vous paraît irresponsable
Brigitte boucher
ce sont à 6 ans en face de vous revenir
sur les jours importants à l'Assemblée
bonsoir Mathilde panot la commission
mixte paritaire va se réunir mercredi il
y aura dedans deux députés de la France
insoumise dont vous d'ailleurs et Adrien
Clouet vous y allez en tant que que
spectatrice non regardez à l'Assemblée
nationale nous ne sommes pas spectateurs
je le crois et pourtant nous n'avons pas
la majorité absolue d'ailleurs personne
ne l'a dans cette
donc peut-être les gens un peu plus
l'habitude de suivre mais il faut que
les gens comprennent donc vous avez à la
fois 7 députés cette sénateurs et
lorsque vous regardez la composition de
ces 14 parlementaires dans cette CMP dit
parlementaire sur 14 sont favorables à
la réforme donc forcément je vais
expliquerai c'est le poids de la
représentation nationale entre le Sénat
et l'Assemblée c'est pas non plus mais
je veux dire ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que je n'ai pas grand espoir que
la Commission mix paritaire ne soit pas
conclusive mais vous allez quand même
faire de l'obstruction à cette
commission oui on va parler on va on va
expliquer à chaque fois pourquoi nous
sommes vous pouvez faire les différents
points mais vous pensez que ça peut se
terminer autrement que par un consensus
entre les républicains et la majorité
comme on vient de le voir au Sénat
peut-être c'est les républicains on
retrouve une certaine dignité
parlementaire face à ce qui leur a été
opposé peut-être enfin je regardais au
Sénat le loto autoritaire qui a été
utilisé alors d'abord on a utilisé
l'article 38 du simplement sa limite les
interventions quand vous présentez les
amendements à un pour un contre ensuite
ils ont réécrit l'article 7 ce qui a
fait tomber à peu près un millier
d'amendements ensuite ils ont utilisé
l'article 42 du règlement qui limite le
temps d'intervention de chaque groupe
ensuite l'article 44 qui met en priorité
certains amendements ce qui faisait
tomber d'autres amendements vous dire si
la réponse à l'obstruction de la gauche
tout ça parce que il ne pouvait pas
avancer parce qu'il y avait c'est
totalement 70 amendements de suppression
mais c'est constitution alors oui c'est
tout ça est constitutionnel mais ça note
ça dénote quand même un certain regard
sur la démocratie c'est la dernière fois
qu'il a été utilisé au Sénat c'était la
gauche qu'il a utilisé pour la réforme
Touraine
oui bah je suis contre la réforme
Touraine et ce n'est pas contre la
réforme
de choses entre rien que le choix du
véhicule législatif qui est le fait
d'avoir utilisé un véhicule législatif
qui est un projet de loi rectificatif du
budget de la Sécurité sociale pourquoi
parce qu'il leur permet d'utiliser si il
le souhaite le 43 et on verra notamment
je dis ce qui se passera nous nous avons
un problème avec l'utilisation d'un d'un
projet de loi rectificatif normalement
c'est pour bon corriger à la marge des
choses qui ont été votées pour le budget
de l'année à venir là qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ils l'utilisent pour un projet de
fond on n'a jamais vu ça alors on
reviendra là dessus mais je voudrais
vous entendre sur la CMP encore la
commission mix paritaire est-ce que vous
voulez la rendre publique parce que
Boris Vallot le président du groupe est
ici à l'Assemblée nationale souhaiterait
qu'elle soit qu'elle ne soit pas huis
clos alors que c'est toujours le cas il
va en parler demain à la Conférence des
présidents de l'Assemblée vous le
suivrez là-dessus oui moi je défendrai
moi aussi cette
c'est quand même la première fois que
nous avons une commission mixte
paritaire avec l'Assemblée nationale qui
n'a pas voté le texte pas voter
l'article 7 et qui n'a pas examiné tout
un tas des articles qui sont dans le
projet de loi première des choses et
deuxième chose avec c'est la première
fois qu'on arrive avec un texte qui en
plus de ça a été adopté je vous faisais
la liste des articles du Règlement
jusqu'au vote bloqué qui est le plus
grave donc avec un bon un passage en
force qui a été fait sur cette question
ça changerait quoi ça change rien
exactement
Adrien Chloé moi-même nous la fuite la
commission pour que vous puissiez la
suivre nous sortirons régulièrement et
vous nous raconterez en fait comprenez
que quand le débat pourquoi est-ce que
le débat est publique à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat par ailleurs c'est
parce que chacun et chacune peut alors
suivre les débats et donc je trouve
intéressant dans un moment où ce texte
n'a pas été discuté dans beaucoup des
aspects je trouve intéressant que les
citoyens alors la suite de la commission
mixte paritaire et bien c'est le texte
qui devrait en sortir jeudi avec le vote
au Sénat à l'Assemblée pour l'instant le
gouvernement affirme vouloir éviter le
recours à l'article 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que vous y croyez
s'ils n'ont pas de majorité ils
utiliseront le 49,3 et s'il n'avait pas
voulu utiliser le 49-3 alors ils
auraient choisi un projet de loi
classique qui nous aurait donné le temps
d'étudier vous y attendez une réforme
qui va changer la vie d'ailleurs des
générations futures donc je ne suis pas
naïve sur cette question là s'ils n'ont
pas la majorité ils utiliseront 49-3 ce
qui pour le coup sera quand même une
preuve de faiblesse de ce pouvoir
extrêmement forte parce que de nouveau
on aura un passage en force mais vous
pensez que sa majorité ou pas
j'en sais autant que vous moi j'entends
des LR qui disent que ils voteront
contre la réforme notamment parce qu'il
l'a trouvé le gouvernement en train
d'essayer de chercher des voix
les réunions à Matignon se multiplient
avec celles et ceux qui siégeront à la
CMP de la part de la majorité donc je
vois bien que les tractations vont bon
train et qu'ils espèrent on arrivera
avec les élus de la CMP LR sont à
Matignon
vous voulez la suppression du 49-3 vous
avez des collègues écologistes qui le
réclament c'est dans notre programme
présidentiel effectivement et donc vous
allez vous joindre à ceux qui le
réclament à travers une proposition de
loi est-ce que selon vous le fait de
recourir aux 49-3 peut relancer la
mobilisation parce qu'on l'a vu la
mobilisation elle était un peu plus
terne samedi dernier est-ce que vous
attendez du coup avec cette ce recours à
ce coup de force pour vous une nouvelle
mobilisation dans la rue déjà je vous le
dis quand même parce que parce que c'est
mon rôle de vous le dire mais la théorie
de la mobilisation qui s'essouffle en
nous la jouer à peu près à chaque
semaine de mobilisation
alors juste je reprécise la semaine
dernière il y avait le 7 mars où il y
avait 3,5 millions de manifestants selon
la CGT
et ensuite avec samedi 1 million de
manifestants avec d'ailleurs des gens un
peu différents de ceux qui 338000 selon
le ministère de l'Intérieur donner les
chiffres il y a aucun souci
en perspective non mais vous donnez
l'information complète il y a aucun
souci là-dessus mais juste moi je je me
base sur les chiffres des syndicats donc
avec des gens qui étaient un peu
différents dans les manifestations de
samedi mais il faut quand même imaginer
que là on est dans un moment où depuis
mardi vous avez des personnes qui sont
dans des piquets de grève 24 heures sur
24 mois à Ivry-sur-Seine j'ai
l'incinérateur qui est bloqué depuis
mardi les éboueurs qui font grève depuis
lundi et qui dorment 24 heures sur 24
sur les sites donc vous imaginez que ce
ne sont pas la France n'est pas bloqué
vous aviez appelé comme la CGT un
blocage de la France elle n'est pas
bloquée c'est un outil en moi pour peser
bah écoutez je pense que je conseille à
tout le monde d'aller faire son plein
d'essence assez rapidement quand je vois
ce qu'on décider les raffineries quand
je vois que on se rend compte finalement
en disant cela c'est moi je la pénurie
mais écoutez je vous dis ça parce que
vous avez des secteurs extrêmement
mobilisés sur les déchets moi je trouve
ça incroyable que d'un coup on se rend
compte que oui les éboueurs ont un
métier essentiel dans ce pays et que
ceux qui sont si mal payés dans notre
pays et qui surtout ont une espérance de
vie moyenne de 3 ans inférieures à
d'autres personnes de la population et
bien d'un coup on se rend compte que oui
il joue un rôle essentiel évidemment
dans la question du ramassage de déchets
ensuite de l'incinération ou autre de
déchets mais aussi dans des questions
sanitaires et donc je pense qu'on doit
respecter aussi mettre ce qui est en
train de dire là le pape le français
dans sa majeure qui continuent des
grèves je voudrais votre interprétation
de ce que dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon il dit
qu'il veut une porte de sortie par la
force qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire par là
alors il dit surtout qu'il faut une
porte de sortie par le haut si vous
voulez
si on a un gouvernement qui continue à
écouter ni rien ni personne écoutez
quand vous êtes dans un conflit
légitimité parce que d'un côté vous avez
le président de la République qui vous
explique qu'il a été élu pour faire
cette réforme des retraites à 64 ou 65
ans il donc il met une légitimité dans
la balance nous on lui rétorque que le
soir du second tour des élections
présidentielles il avait alors dit je
sais que beaucoup de Français ont voté
pour moi pas pour mon programme et ce
vote mobile donc il y a aussi d'autres
légitimités vous avez la légitimité de
ce qui s'est passé aux élections
législatives la légitimité des
organisations syndicales qui eux aussi
sont des personnes qui sont élues par
les salariés de ce pays et vous surtout
vous avez une légitimité populaire
lorsque vous avez autant de gens qui se
déclarent défavorables à cette réforme
la seule solution c'est d'en sortir par
le haut et donc
c'est par la force non vous avez entendu
par la force non bah par la force il
parlait des blocages qui sont faits de
des rapports de force
de faire mais vous avez entendu Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dire retrait au référendum et
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'ailleurs de
l'Inter syndical le disent beaucoup
d'autres aussi personnes de la nuit
passe le disent donc voilà ce que ce que
nous disons quand vous avez quand vous
êtes dans une situation inextricable
comme ça à un moment il faut en sortir
par la démocratie et non pas par la
force à tout va et notamment par ses
outils anti-démocratiques qui sont
utilisés alors la démocratie c'est aussi
l'Assemblée en cas de 49,3 est-ce que
vous déposerez une motion de censure
évidemment voilà et si et si par exemple
il y a il y a pas de 49,3 qui a un vote
est-ce que vous déposerez une motion de
censure spontanée oui vous avez vous
avez dans dans cet examen d'un texte
tous tous les outils les uns après les
autres tous les outils antidémocratiques
de la Cinquième République qui ont été
utilisés pour faire passer en force
Intex et nous on veut savoir dans quels
utiliserez vous la motion
nous ferons soit et où une motion
arctique 49-3 de la Constitution ou une
motion 49,2 donc oui nous déposerons une
motion quoi qu'il arrive avec qui alors
une notion transpartisane on entend
parler de ça avec peut-être le groupe
liotte est-ce que vous vous êtes
d'accord pour vous associer à d'autres
groupes à tous les groupes à qui oui non
on serait d'accord pour porter une
motion avec avec yacht ça vous a pas
échappé d'ailleurs que nous avions déjà
déposé une motion avec le groupe
lors du début de la réforme des
retraites donc le rassemblement national
oui sans le rassemblement national mais
je pense que ça on arrivera ça ferait
une motion de l'iode quelques LR et puis
la nuit pesque prêt à se joindre à vous
vous avez vous coucher avec elle avec du
côté de la droite il y aurait combien de
républicain alors ça je ne sais pas
c'est une poignée c'est je ne sais pas
le RN il n'en est pas question non il
n'en est pas même si ça vous permet
d'obtenir évidemment le roi et nous
n'avons jamais consigné une notion en
revanche vous êtes d'accord pour le RN
votre émotion enfin vous l'appeler à
voter votre émotion non mais je vous ai
déjà expliqué que on ne pouvait pas
s'étaler sur les boutons des députés
rassemblement national et que donc on
appelait enfin évidemment on appelle les
députés à voter notre émotion mais il
n'y a pas d'appel particulier au
rassemblement national sur je ne sais
quoi après nous proposons nous proposons
une motion et ensuite chaque député
prend ses responsabilités alors le RN
aussi va déposer une notion là vous la
votez ou pas et bien écoutez à chaque
fois que ça s'est passé ça s'est passé
de temps en temps de temps en temps il
se prennent à déposer une motion et bien
comme nous sommes plus nombreux que
c'est la notre qui examiné en premier et
donc la leur est en quelque sorte
inutile derrière donc nous voilà elle ne
sert à rien c'est le rassemblement
national a inventé dans cette
législature quelque chose d'absolument
incroyable c'est-à-dire une opposition
qui ne s'oppose pas voilà alors la
motion de censure le but c'est de faire
tomber le gouvernement est-ce que vous
espérez y arriver et dans ce cas
qu'est-ce que vous attendez d'une
dissolution est-ce que vous pensez que
vous pourriez revenir beaucoup plus
nombreux ici à l'Assemblée nationale on
a eu un on a eu un bon aperçu vous avez
vu que fin janvier il y avait trois
élections législatives partielles il y a
un député RN qui a été battu et surtout
nous avons récupéré
un poste de député enfin nous avons
gagné en supplémentaire parce que
récupérer on a l'impression que ça a été
réduit il a été réélu alors qu'il a été
élu nouvellement René Pilato député de
la première circonscription de Charente
donc oui je pense que ça vous serez
favorable une dissolution écoutez à un
moment enfin voilà nous on dit dans tous
les cas le peuple et la solution est
donc revenir devant le peuple nous
paraît être aussi une option
intéressante est-ce que vous comptez
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel et sur
quoi après cette réforme des retraites
alors oui évidemment on va saisir le
Conseil constitutionnel d'abord sur je
le disais le choix du véhicule
législatif qui nous paraît problématique
en termes de direction
et puis exactement sur une réforme de
fond je disais c'est la première fois
donc on veut interroger le Conseil
constitutionnel et d'ailleurs on était
le seul groupe à avoir saisi le Conseil
d'État aussi sur cette question sur
cette question là et puis ensuite sur
toute une sorte une série de d'articles
ou d'amendements qui ont été faits au
projet de loi et qui l'index le Seigneur
par exemple tout ce qui est cavalier
social un budget rien du tout rien du
tout donc vous allez avoir tout donc on
va saisir sur tous les points qui nous
semblent importants et puis voilà mais
vous allez est-ce que vous allez faire
un recours commun avec par exemple la
gauche sénatoriale qui est déjà annonce
elle-même des recours des recours aussi
sur les conditions d'examen de la
réforme le recours à l'article 38 dont
vous parliez etc que comment vous
travaillez là avec alors je vous avoue
que je ne sais j'ai pas encore eu la
discussion avec les groupes de gauche et
écologistes au Sénat mais pourquoi pas
c'est une possibilité en tout cas en
tout cas qu'on travaille en commun sur
un recours oui oui ça me paraît vous
pensez que ça peut tomber
que ce texte peut finalement être jamais
appliquer Laurent Fabius lui-même qui
vous explique qu'il y a quand même des
problèmes de constitutionnalité alors il
parlait de l'index senior mais de
d'autres choses ça peut ça se tente donc
l'avenir c'est peut-être comme le CPE
c'est à dire que ça ne soit jamais
finalement appliqué ça c'est possible et
d'ailleurs c'est un très bon exemple que
vous redonnez là parce que ça ça permet
aussi aux gens de comprendre que quel
que soit l'option qui s'appelle une loi
votée en 2006 quel que soit l'option qui
se déroule jeudi c'est-à-dire vote ou
49-3 puisque ça sera un des deux donc
quel que soit le passage de cette loi
que ça soit de force ou avec un vote RIC
rock moi je le dis ce n'est pas terminé
pour autant et effectivement le CPE en
est un exemple puisque le CPE n'avait
jamais été appliqué notamment parce que
les mobilisations avaient continué donc
j'appelle tout le monde à avoir plein de
force et des Sports pour la suite parce
que quand vous avez des ministres qui
commencent à déraper régulièrement que
ça soit par des gestes déplacés pour
nous expliquer que quand nous sommes en
grève nous créons une catalogue
etc ça c'est Olivier je pense que que
Monsieur du stop nous explique que
personne n'a craqué vous comprenez que
ils sont en train de craquer les uns
après les autres et donc que nous tenons
de bonbons alors on parle constitution
l'Élysée annonce un projet de là pour
inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution en
affichant sa préférence sur la rédaction
du Sénat parle de liberté et non d'un
droit est-ce que c'est pour vous une
bonne chose je rappelle que vous étiez
vous à l'origine de la proposition de
loi qui a été adoptée à l'Assemblée
exactement alors bon il y a deux choses
sur ce projet de loi constitutionnel le
premier qui m'inquiète le plus avant de
parler de la rédaction le premier qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est quand Emmanuel
Macron explique que ça sera dans un
projet de loi globale de changement de
la Constitution qui est mais pour le
coup la responsabilité d'Emmanuel Macron
et engager directement ça sera sa
responsabilité puisqu'il y aura de fait
un échec sur cette question là et je le
redis au côté de toutes les associations
du planning familial des collectifs et
de tant d'autres qui s'engagent depuis
des années sur cette question si nous
n'avons pas un projet de loi séparé qui
garantit le fait qu'on arrive
ça sera dans effectivement une réforme
constitutionnelle ils peuvent encore
changer d'avis parce que sérieusement
sinon on y arrivera pas donc ça ça c'est
le premier des points le deuxième point
vous avez vous avez raison nous on avait
mis le droit à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse pendant que le Sénat avait
préféré le mot liberté bien évidemment
je préfère le mot droit mais je pense
que ce qui est le plus important c'est
que si on fait un projet de loi séparé
alors la France deviendrait le premier
pays au monde et si c'est liberté
l'annonce d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
terrible enfin ça veut dire que on
aurait pu envoyer un signal à des
millions de femmes à la fois en Europe
aux États-Unis qui se battent et un peu
partout mais c'est perdu d'avortement
vous pouvez trouver un accord avec la
majorité là dessus vous savez le projet
de loi constitutionnel qui va nous être
présenté va être une sorte de remake
avec d'autres choses de ce qui s'était
passé avant l'affaire Benalla et qui
avait échoué avec l'affaire Benalla et
nous étions en désaccord
écoutez c'est quand même pas notre
responsabilité nous sommes nous ne
sommes pas par exemple d'accord avec le
bon ben on va pas voter pour le
septennat pour qu'il y ait l'IVG donc
ils prennent ces responsabilités et que
on met enfin ce droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution l'assemblée à avoir tes
pour le Sénat a voté pour dans des
termes qui ne sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes mais je veux dire le signal qu'on
pourrait envoyer est tellement important
pour des millions de femmes je veux dire
juste à côté de chez nous les Hongroises
vous savez ce que Emmanuel Macron à
torpillé le projet d'inscription est-ce
que vous dites à vouloir le faire dans
un projet global
merci beaucoup Brigitte Etam bonjour
Vincent roux en direct du Figaro live
merci à vous à la première question
d'actualité à Mathilde panneau ce soir
une question que vous avez abordé tout à
l'heure c'est la question justement de
la gestion des ordures avec le blocage
effectivement d'un certain nombre
d'usines d'incinération notamment à
Ivry-sur-Seine vous le disiez tout à
l'heure mais également à
Issy-les-Moulineaux qu'est-ce qu'on fait
dans cette situation si vous étiez maire
de Paris par exemple 5400 tonnes au
moins un ordures qui ne sont pas
collectés vous laissez faire ou bien
est-ce que il faut demander la
réquisition comme le demande d'ailleurs
comme le suggère Gabriel Attal
d'agents pour ramasser ses ordures qui
pose quand même un problème sanitaire
oui ça pose un problème sanitaire et ça
rappelle à quel point ces agents sont
essentiels et font un travail essentiel
qui devrait être bien mieux reconnu dans
notre pays le droit de grève est un
droit de grève constitutionnel et il
n'existe pas de service minimum dans ce
qui concerne les déchets et je vois bien
ce qui se passe au Royaume-Uni notamment
où c'est par cette partie là qu'on a des
tricoté en quelque sorte restreint le
droit de grève donc moi je je suis
contre la réquisition parce que la
question à un moment c'est de dire
lorsque vous avez des millions de gens
qui défilent dans la rue depuis des
semaines lorsque vous avez des personnes
qui ne font pas grève pour le plaisir
qui perdent tous les jours des journées
de salaire pour pouvoir dire nous ne
pouvons pas continuer jusqu'à 64 ans
vous savez moi j'ai vu je vous dis juste
cela mais des éboueurs à Ivry-sur-Seine
qui vous raconte les larmes aux yeux
qu'ils ont vu trois de leurs collègues
décédés juste avant leur retraite qui
est aujourd'hui à 62 ans donc 64 ans ils
ne peuvent pas l'envisager donc je
propose qu'on réponde à leur
revendications plutôt que de leur
accuser
maintenant le gouvernement visiblement
ne s'apprête pas à répondre à ces
revendications qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
laisse les ordures continuent à
s'avancer
non on répond à leurs rêves indication
c'est ce que disait à l'instant pour
reprendre la question de Vincent si vous
étiez maire d'une grande ville où il y a
ces grèves d'éboueurs qui posent des
problèmes sanitaires vous répondez
comment pour protéger votre population
je vous administrer je réponds aux
administrés que je comprends à quel
point c'est la galère à quel point c'est
dangereux ce qui est en train de se
passer j'ai vu que ça n'a pas des vidéos
avec des rats qui sont en train depuis
les deux partout mais que ce tant que le
gouvernement refusera d'écouter
absolument tout le monde dans ce pays on
ne peut rien faire vous le faites rien
en tant que mère d'une ville vous ne
faites rien moi je soutiens les
grévistes oui
je ne suis pas mère je suis président
mais peut-être un jour je serais vous
Mathilde panot merci beaucoup Vincent à
tout à l'heure bonjour Yves Thréard
directeur de la rédaction du Figaro
c'est à VOUS bonsoir Mathilde panot
alors fin février juste après l'examen
du texte des retraites à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a eu un sondage qui est
paru dans Les Echos et un sondage fort
intéressant qui dit que pour beaucoup de
Français
66% des Français l'attitude de la France
insoumise est dangereuse alors que la
même question posée à propos du
rassemblement national on arrive à 49%
c'est à dire moins de la majorité
comment vous expliquer ça alors bon déjà
vous vous me prenez un sondage je
pourrais vous en prendre beaucoup
d'autres aussi sur par exemple oui mais
je pourrais vous prendre d'autres
sondages sur par exemple le nombre de
Français qui considère que la France
insoumise est une opposition et la
meilleure opposition à ce que fait
Emmanuel Macron mais je ne vais pas
esquiver la question que vous me posez
d'abord je crois que ce qui s'est passé
au Sénat
repose la question de ce que nous avons
fait à l'Assemblée et je dois vous dire
et bien je dois vous dire que moi je
suis heureuse que grâce à nous grâce à
la nupesse nous ayons levé tout un tas
de lièvres sur les mensonges du
gouvernement les 1200 euros les femmes
grandes gagnantes les carrières longues
notamment avec les LR etc mais je suis
aussi heureuse de savoir que grâce à
nous ce texte n'a pas de légitimité
parlementaire et que le fait de ne pas
avoir voté ni l'article 7 ni le texte de
loi dans son ensemble a aidé le
mouvement social à continuer
en l'occurrence au Sénat manifestation
me dit aussi beaucoup ça vous devriez
venir avec moi mais pourquoi pas au
Sénat il a été voté le texte oui et bien
justement
fait en sorte qu'il ne soit pas voté ça
vous arrangeait en fait qu'il soit pas
voté non mais comprenez quand vous avez
des millions de personnes qui sont dans
la rue vous avez des millions à chaque
fois il y a eu au maximum un million
200000 personnes ça dépend si vous
prenez les chiffres des syndicats moi je
prends les chiffres des syndicats donc
vous vous dites pas des millions mais
moi accepter que je dise des millions
voilà bon bah si vous voulez mais même
quand vous prenez les chiffres police
c'est la plus grande manifestation qu'il
y a eu depuis 50 ans dans ce pays enfin
un moment ça devrait faire réfléchir un
peu les gens non les manifs contre la
réforme des retraites de Nicolas Sarkozy
3 millions de personnes oui non mais
alors là vous prenez les chiffres on va
pas passer
vous serez pas d'accord là d'ailleurs
par ailleurs c'est vraiment les la plus
grosse manifestation qui est depuis 50
ans mais bon passons passons sur cette
question là
j'étais sur
donc vous l'aviez
instruction
mais oui mais parce que comprenez voilà
c'est ça que j'étais en train de dire
comprenez que quand il y a des millions
de personnes qui manifestent qu'il y a
des mouvements de grève qui se
déclenchent un peu partout que nous
notre rôle c'est d'avoir à la fois un
pied dedans un pied dehors et donc de
ramener aussi ceux qui se passe dans
dans la rue et dans les mouvements
sociaux dans l'Inter syndical aussi à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle et ce que
nous nous avons fait c'est laisser le
temps au mouvement social le temps de
s'organiser pour pouvoir organiser la
lutte contre la raison
que des propos agréables pour vous c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai mais il a tout à
fait le droit d'avoir son appréciation
sur ce que nous avons fait mais je le
dis nous avons une certaine expérience
maintenant des combats parlementaires et
par exemple ceux qui s'est passé au
Sénat avec le fait de faire un
amendement de réécriture qui fait tomber
l'ensemble des derrière et qui fait que
l'article est immédiatement voté et bien
c'était une des raisons pour lequel nous
avons déposé beaucoup d'amendements et
j'en ajoute une deuxième c'est que quand
vous regardez le gouvernement au fur et
à mesure alors au départ vous expliquer
c'était une réforme juste et équilibrée
de progrès c'était une réforme qui
allait aider pour financer les hôpitaux
vous voyez comment ils sont en train de
s'effondrer bon donc et puis petit à
petit ils ont abandonné ça parce que
plus on montrait les mensonges plus ils
avaient moins ils avaient d'arguments
donc le seul argument qui leur restait
c'est celui qui a dit Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui c'est de dire cette réforme
elle est nécessaire et bien nous nous
avons avec des milliers d'amendements
sur le financement qui était la première
partie du projet de loi démontré que
nous pourrions faire tout autrement j'en
reviens au fait que pour 66% des
Français au terme de ce sondage il vous
juge dangereux votre attitude dangereuse
c'est quand même c'est quand même très
grave comme qualification alors que vous
êtes démocratiquement élu alors que vous
siégé à l'Assemblée nationale alors que
vous êtes un parti qui a pignon sur rue
vous rendez compte vous êtes
actuellement je pense que ça va député
quatre fois du socle par exemple
regardez si vous regardez des sondages
vous vous demandez aux Français est-ce
que ce qu'il pense que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui est dangereux ou le blocage
d'Emmanuel Macron qui s'obstine pour son
seul ego à vouloir continuer ce texte
contre tout le monde et bien je pense
que vous obtiendrez des scores
extrêmement élevés donc je ne sais pas
exactement de quel son d'agent j'en
parle mais je vous fais confiance sur le
sondage mais ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que il y a aussi des millions de
gens dans ce pays qui nous ont élu pour
une chose pour nous opposer à la
politique d'Emmanuel maintenant proposer
une autre ce que nous faisons et donc
nous faisons ce pourquoi nous avons été
élu vous avez quelqu'un dans vos rang
qui s'appelle Christophe Becks et qui a
eu cette phrase assez intéressante nous
aspirons à gouverner et voulons être
responsable mais en même temps nous nous
sommes pleinement investis nous portons
une charge émotif forte nous ne sommes
pas tous expérimentés c'est à dire que
on a l'impression qu'il y a deux lignes
dans vos rangs avec une ligne
extrêmement dur raide de confrontation
et une ligne qui de se montrer une ligne
de gouvernement et bien ce qui a gagné
aux élections présidentielles parce que
parfois on essaye un peu d'effacer
c'était seulement il y a 8 9 mois les
élections présidentielles pourquoi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a-t-il fait 8
millions de voix notamment parce que
nous avions un programme qui était à la
fois un programme parmi les plus sérieux
et quand vous regardez le nombre
d'associations et d'ONG qui ont évalué
les programmes généralement nous avions
les meilleures notes il faut dire que
généralement nous avons repris aussi
beaucoup de leur propositions et qui
était aussi un programme de rupture et
c'est sur ce programme de rupture que
nous avons fait la nuit Pesse donc nous
tenons nos deux bouts à la fois
évidemment la ligne de la rupture et je
dois dire que je suis très fière quand
je vois des gens qui s'identifient
fortement à l'Assemblée nationale
lorsqu'il voit Rachel kéké première
femme de ménage jamais élue à
l'Assemblée nationale lorsqu'il voit
Caroline Fiat qui est devenue
vice-présidente de l'Assemblée alors que
les députés macronistes l'appelaient la
député Batman 2 parce que c'était une
aide-soignante quand je vois beaucoup
d'entre eux d'entre eux qui sont
première ouvrière agricole jamais il lui
a l'Assemblée nationale et bien oui nous
quand Christophe Becks dit nous partons
une charge émotive c'est parce que et
bien je crois que le groupe insoumis a
permis notamment au peuple ne rend toute
sa diversité de rentrer à l'Assemblée
nationale et que cela crée aussi et oui
quand il dit charge émotive des
représentations de gens très fortes qui
disent sauf qu'il y a quand même eu un
coup de grisou important il y a pas très
longtemps dans notre mouvement bah oui
vous le savez très bien vous vous en
avez pas fait les frais parce que vous
avez été vous êtes présidente du groupe
à l'Assemblée nationale mais manuel
montpar a été aussi promu en quelque
sorte comme le successeur du grand chef
qui est Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais tous les
autres ont été écartés de la direction
du mouvement
ils en nourrissent une certaine amertume
en tous les cas oui mais en fait si vous
voulez rentrer sur la manière dont nous
fonctionnons nous avons alors pour le
groupe parlementaire un bureau dont son
membre Alexis Corbière clémentinottin
François Ruffin et autres ensuite nous
avons une coordination des espaces qui
est effectivement coordonnées manuel
Bompard qui a été accessoirement deux
fois le directeur de campagne de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et qui depuis des
années travail dans avec le mouvement
pour développer le mouvement de la
France insoumise donc je trouve ça très
justifié et puis ensuite un conseil
politique auquel le parti de Clémentine
Autain a été invité auquel le parti de
François Ruffin a été invité et
d'ailleurs son représentés dans ce
conseil politique donc personne n'a été
purgé et je rappelle juste que si on
parle de François Ruffin de Clémentine
Autain par exemple il ne fait pas partie
de l'ancienne coordination donc personne
ne cherche à purger personne et je crois
que encore tout à l'heure j'avais le
bureau de mon groupe je crois que il y a
justement des espaces dans lequel nous
discutons et nous avançons sur ce que
nous voulons faire collectivement alors
vous avez sans doute souffrir de ne pas
avoir de groupe à la soirée au Sénat à
la Haute Assemblée pendant cette
discussion sur les retraites là il va y
avoir il va plupart des élections
sénatoriales là est-ce que vous avez
est-ce que vous travaillez pour obtenir
des sièges de sénateurs alors ça je ne
sais pas vous dire où on en est sur
cette sur cette question là puisque
c'est plutôt le pôle élection du
mouvement qui s'en occupe bon vous savez
nous on n'a pas beaucoup de grands
électeurs ce qui explique jusqu'à
l'heure donc en gros voilà aux élections
sénatoriales nous n'y avions pas de
candidature alors là pour cette fois-ci
je ne sais pas vous dire on verra je
vais redemander aux instances qui s'en
occupent dans le mouvement mais oui
après l'idée c'est que on investisse
tous les espaces démocratiques qu'on
peut dernière question le chef
incontesté incontestable chez vous reste
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a une légitimité
extrêmement forte trois fois candidat à
l'élection présidentielle 8 millions de
voix la dernière fois et j'aimerais bien
que
parfois on reconnaisse que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et celui et je n'en vois pas
d'autres en politique il y a fait
multiplier par 5 le groupe parlementaire
de la France insoumise celui qui est
notamment à l'origine de la création de
la nuit passe et puis celui qui a réussi
aussi à faire monter auprès des médias
notamment beaucoup de jeunes d'une jeune
génération donc oui il est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est quelqu'un de très
important et reste quelqu'un de très
important pour nous il y a pas très
longtemps disait il nous manque à
l'Assemblée nationale oui bah oui on
aimerait qu'il garde un mandat de député
bah non mais je pense vous avez
peut-être vu ce qu'il fait à l'Institut
La Boétie mais je trouve ça passionnant
ce qu'il est en train de faire à la fois
pour recréer des choses hégémoniques sur
en travaillant avec des géographes qui
sont internationalement connus en
travaillant sur la longue histoire sur
plein de choses donc je pense que il a
un rôle qui est un rôle très utile aussi
et que chacun nous portons ensemble le
combat à nos différents postes merci
beaucoup
pour le débat une question de société
tiens la fin de vie c'est au programme
de la réflexion du convention citoyenne
installée par Emmanuel Macron qui
souhaite si on peut si on doit faire
évoluer la loi qui instaure les soins
palliatifs à l'hôpital faut-il légaliser
ou pas le suicide assisté et même le
l'euthanasie d'abord le principe même de
cette convention citoyenne ce sont des
citoyens tirés au sort qui réfléchissent
à une question aussi passionnelle aussi
partagée est-ce que là vous dites il y a
quelque chose de pas mal le Président
nous on avait soutenu la commission
citoyenne sur sur le climat et
d'ailleurs je trouve intéressant dans le
de ce qui ressort pour
ceux qui ressort là pour l'instant sur
les débats sur la question de la fin de
vie et de l'euthanasie sont bon quand
même une large majorité qui est
favorable à ce qu'on a à ce qu'on crée
ce nouveau droit pour les personnes donc
moi je trouve ça intéressant la question
de mère toujours la même c'est que c'est
intéressant de mener ces travaux là mais
à la fin qui décide et si c'est pour
faire comme la convention citoyenne pour
le climat ou on crée un énorme travail
de la part de citoyens et à la fin on
jette 80% à la poubelle de ce qu'ils ont
fait là je ne suis pas d'accord
je sur la sur la question de la fin de
vie du droit à mourir dans la dignité ou
de l'euthanasie nous nous avons été
comme groupe parlementaire en 2018 les
premiers à déposer dans notre niche
parlementaire une proposition de loi que
portait à l'époque Caroline Fiat pour
créer ce droit à l'euthanasie je crois
que ça fait par où vous êtes pour la
légalisation oui je crois que ça fait
partie des droits nouveaux c'est une
liberté de chacun et chacune de pouvoir
d'un bout à l'autre de sa vie être
maître de soi et décider de quand on
peut éteindre la lumière je vous
présente mais vous le connaissez le
député du Bas-Rhin porte-parole du
groupe Renaissance Charles Gisen Soult
merci bonsoir et merci à vous d'avoir
accepté avec Mathilde pano de débattre
ensemble avec un sujet très important
qui est arrivé aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
et qui est l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire c'est à VOUS absolument donc
on est depuis cet après-midi sur
l'examen du texte nucléaire et j'étais
présent en hémicycle et donc j'ai eu
l'occasion d'entendre les propos et
maintenant de votre groupe et je suis en
fait assez compris d'entendre que votre
groupe va s'opposer à ce texte puisque
la filière nucléaire est une filière
historique d'excellence de la France
c'est une grande aventure collective à
la fois scientifique et surtout
industrielle moi j'avais toujours cru
comprendre que que la gauche était
attachée à l'industrie et donc c'est
assez contradictoire j'aimerais que vous
nous expliquer pourquoi est-ce que vous
êtes opposé à cette relance du nucléaire
voulue par le président de la République
alors déjà ne soyez pas surpris c'était
dans notre programme présidentiel nous
nous sommes effectivement pour la sortie
planifiée du nucléaire il s'agit pas du
jour au lendemain d'arrêter mais parce
que alors pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que c'est aujourd'hui ce qui
empêche le développement des énergies
renouvelables quand vous devez mettre
100 milliards dans le grand carénage
pour pouvoir prolonger les centrales en
construire d'autres et bien c'est autant
d'argent que vous ne mettez pas dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
un problème de résilience de l'énergie
nucléaire je parle évidemment des
refroidissements des réacteurs et on est
en sécheresse hivernale donc la question
du refroidissement quand parfois il est
arrivé en période ne sécheresse que la
moitié des réacteurs soit à l'arrêt soit
pour des questions de maintenance soit
pour des questions justement de
refroidissement et puis pour des
questions géopolitiques regardez que là
on est en train d'importer de Russie ça
doit quand même nous poser des questions
là-dessus par ailleurs nous n'avons pas
d'uranium dans notre pays donc ça pose
un problème de souveraineté la troisième
chose et qui est très importante pour
moi vous savez moi je suis
sous-traitante d'une association
marraine pardon d'une association de
sous-traitants nucléaire donc la
question de l'emploi et des conditions
d'emploi dans le nucléaire m'intéressent
beaucoup il se trouve que 80% de la
maintenance nucléaire est faite
aujourd'hui par des sous-traitants dans
des conditions de travail qui sont
vraiment très mauvaises avec des gens
qui n'ont pas le statut et je le dis
nous avons sur cette question un gros
problème sur l'excellence dont vous
parlez parce que nous sommes en train de
perdre avec cette sous-traitance la
connaissance des réacteurs quant au
scandale Creusot forge ça vous dit
quelque chose donc moi je veux qu'on
développe une des filières d'énergie
renouvelables d'excellence et que on
arrête petit à petit avec une énergie
qui est plus chère que les énergies
renouvelables qui est dangereuse qui
produit des déchets dont on ne sait que
faire et qui est surtout non résiliente
aux aléas climatiques ce qu'il faut
faire et ce que la France a commencé à
faire d'ailleurs d'autres pays le font
c'est les deux en réalité c'est d'avoir
le nucléaire et c'est de développer
davantage les énergies renouvelablement
la voté une loi il y a quelques semaines
d'ailleurs vous vous y êtes aussi
opposés c'est contradictoires
la filière la filière nucléaire
française ne va pas bien depuis
plusieurs années mais pourquoi parce que
on a détourné nos plus brillants esprits
de cette filière là par un matraquage
médiatique par un lobby intensif de vos
amis écologistes et aussi d'un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont qui sont
proches de la France insoumise et qu'on
a dégouté des jeunes françaises et des
jeunes Français de s'engager dans cette
filière heureusement cette filière elle
est résiliente elle se relance et elle
fait la fierté et surtout elle fait
l'indépendance énergétique du pays donc
votre discours est contradictoire et
surtout totalement hors sol d'une
certaine façon parce qu'on aura toujours
besoin d'énergie on aura toujours besoin
d'électricité et que notamment le parc
automobile sera c'est un fait de plus en
plus électrique donc les besoins
d'électricité seront croissants de notre
pays vous voyez en fait en fait la
différence entre vous et moi c'est que
il y a toujours des questions de court
terme vous ne voyez les choses qu'à
court terme et je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est pas possible de faire les
deux quand je vous dis 100 milliards
quand vous regardez le fiasco de l'EPR
vous allez nous expliquer que les EPR 2
dont la technologie n'est toujours pas
faite avec un EPR qui est absolument
dramatique en termes de bilan il devait
coûter 3,3 milliards il en coûtera au
moins 21 milliards il y a un problème
avec la cuve il y a un problème avec le
couvercle il y a un problème avec les
soudures Bouygues a été condamné pour
travail dissimulé avec 150 travailleurs
et je pourrais continuer assez longtemps
les plans de l'EPR sont dans sont dans
la nature ça ça a été révélé par
Greenpeace c'est quand même absolument
incroyable ça n'a inquiété personne vous
voyez sur ces plans notamment la taille
des boulons de portail qui entoure le Pr
donc vous vous m'expliquez qu'avec une
technologies auprd qui n'est pas prête
une technologie SMR vous savez les
petits réacteurs qui auraient qui n'est
pas prête vous allez m'expliquer que
c'est comme ça qu'on va faire face à la
fois au défi énergétique alors que alors
que cette question la technologie qui
n'est pas prête c'est intéressant c'est
pas vrai en fait ce que ce que ce que
vous dites parce que le Pr on sait le
faire
le Pr on sait le faire et il en existe
un en Chine à tihan qui a été fait par
EDF et la vraie question la réacteur la
vraie question sur le Pr c'est pourquoi
est-ce que ce chantier est en réalité je
suis d'accord a été une sorte de fiasco
que nous avons connue pour celui pour
celui de Flamanville et ce qui a été
notamment mis en avant par le rapport
folle s'il y a quelques années c'est que
cette filière nucléaire en France s'est
affaissée pendant plusieurs années qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de manquements que ça
soit chez EDF et que nous avons repris
les choses en main il va pas échapper
que la direction de DF a été changée que
l'État a tapé du point sur la table et
que donc cette filière il faut la
soutenir et moi je trouve dommage que
dans le débat que nous avons cette
semaine sur le nucléaire vous n'ayez pas
donné le signal de vouloir soutenir
cette vidéo quand je vous donne des
arguments enfin excusez-moi mais on a
des arguments en fait la question de la
sécheresse et de l'eau est un argument
la question du coup avec un nucléaire
qui est plus cher que les énergies
renouvelables est un argument la
question des déchets que vous voulez
enfuir dans la nuit
neuronale je crois que c'était la
proposition de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on ne
sait pas faire en fait c'est impossible
il y a un pays il y a un pays qui a
essayé mais il y a des choses à faire
sur le stockage mais par ailleurs vous
avez des énergies dans lesquels il y a
un pays qui a essayé moi je trouve que
je le connais très bien puisqu'il est
frontalié de ma circonscription c'est
l'Allemagne a essayé c'est un la
politique énergétique allemande est un
naufrage depuis 10 ans et ils ont ils
ont que nous allons expliquer du
nucléaire pour des raisons de craint
dogmatique après Fukushima bilan vous
avez aujourd'hui un gouvernement à
moitié écologiste qui rouvre du charbon
et vous importez du gaz de schiste et
vous voulez me faire croire que c'est
différent chez nous dans les vous dire
l'Allemagne
plus d'énergie renouvelables que nous
donc à un moment soit
des énergies carbonées c'est un naufrage
c'est un naufrage de schiste américain
oui ou non oui vous avez réouvert une
centrale à charbon oui ou non oui
temporairement oui
pas de l'argent à la fois dans la
formation de toutes celles et ceux dont
on a besoin pour les énergies
renouvelables
c'était un des objectifs du test que
nous allons
essayer de faire en sorte que on aille
en marche forcée sur le nucléaire avec
aucun retour en arrière possible et
aucun question démocratique derrière et
en plus de ça vous mettez un coin dans
la sûreté nucléaire en demandant à l'IRM
de fusionner avec la SN donc vraiment ce
texte enfin n'a rien à voir avec ce film
à l'heure du dérèglement
mon second sujet plus territorial et là
je voulais plus savoir un échange pour
un peu connaître votre votre sentiment
puisque il y a eu il y a quelques jours
le rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes
et ce qui a vraiment été très mis en
avant dans ce rapport sur la
décentralisation c'est le naufrage
complet de la réforme des grandes
régions alors moi étant alsacien vous
comprendrez que ce sujet me touche
beaucoup puisque il y a eu cette
incompréhension de la disparition de
l'Alsace et de la création de cette
structure voilà très abstraite quel
grand est ce que vous vous êtes plutôt
ouverte à ce qui est des corrections
voilà de ces méga méga régions c'est une
atteinte qu'on soit en cas de coins du
pays alors nous on est même plus que
pour des corrections on est au départ
pour une constituante c'est à dire que
le peuple réécrive la constitution et la
question de la démocratie aux différents
échelons bon évidemment mon attache
beaucoup d'importance à la commune et je
rappelle je le dis en passant que 50%
des mers ruraux sont des retraités dans
ce pays donc si on repousse l'âge de
départ ça va poser des soucis mais bon
je mets ça de côté on est très attaché
évidemment à la commune au département
et évidemment on a ces méga région qui
arrivent et qui posent un problème de
lien démocratique du citoyen avec avec
la région ce sur quoi nous sommes
d'accord moi je pense que la question
des régions elle doit aussi correspondre
à des réalités physiques on avait une
idée pendant la présidentielle après
c'est d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes en
parle sur le problème des bassins
versants de l'eau mais on avait émis une
idée bon c'est une idée à discuter qui
était de dire pourquoi pas faire
correspondre à des bassins versants des
régions qui en quelque sorte permettrait
de donner
la question sur le cycle de l'eau mais
qui permettrait de donner une unité à la
politique de l'eau comme on sait que par
exemple l'eau va être un des grands
problèmes du 21e siècle on peut par
exemple provenir sur des choses voilà
l'Alsace par exemple ça aurait du sens
avec
voilà non mais par exemple ça aurait du
sens avec ça mais qui permet de redonner
à partir de de grands enjeux qu'on a
enfin voilà qu'on a affronté de redonner
une cohérence à ce qu'est la région et
qui ne soit pas quelque chose quelque
chose de complètement déconnecter et
dimanche dans lequel évidemment le
citoyen ne s'y retrouve pas et donc
cette position là je trouve que cette
réponse elle est elle est intéressante
et puis dans le cas de l'Alsace qui
m'intéresse au premier chef
effectivement comme je le disais bon on
est traversé par des plus grands fleuves
d'Europe qui est le rein et il y a il
faut faire
Christophe Béchu annoncera peut-être des
choses là-dessus dans quelques jours et
puis il y a surtout l'une des plus
grandes nappes phréatiques d'Europe donc
un point de vue de l'eau ça fait sens et
puis je crois surtout ce qui est
important avec les régions et ça
d'ailleurs été écrit noir sur blanc par
la Cour des comptes c'est je pense
quelque chose de très important que une
région a besoin d'une cohérence
historique et politique voilà et c'est
sûrement ce qui manquait dans un certain
nombre de ces nouvelles grandes régions
et que donc dans le cas par exemple du
grand test il y avait absolument aucune
cohérence politique à historique à ce à
se découpage alors que la région Alsace
elle a une longue histoire avait une
longue histoire et une cohérence et donc
nous on est plusieurs députés à porter
le retour voilà de cette région Alsace
et on verra ce dans la fameuse
commission transpartisanale et vous êtes
favorable à un retour à la situation
antérieure de découpage
je pense pas parce que par exemple il
faut par exemple dans le cas de la
Normandie et que je serai courant qui a
été fait c'est-à-dire les deux Normandie
ont été réunifiés il y a aucune attente
à ce qu'on refasse la basse et la
Haute-Normandie par exemple dans le cas
du Grand Est on voit très bien que cette
région ça n'a pas pris auprès de la
population et que il y a surtout ce
territoire l'Alsace qui est quand même
pas un territoire neutre dans l'histoire
de France qui s'est senti vraiment pris
de front et il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
cohérence voilà géographique et
historique et donc nous allons
travailler à son retour et pour aller un
petit peu au-delà ou plus dans le détail
est-ce qu'il y a un échelon territorial
que vous voudriez supprimer ce qu'il y
en a trop
oui bah par exemple un échange
territorial qui nous semblerait
intéressant de supprimer tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui par exemple moi je vis dans
un territoire dans lequel il y a des EPT
donc des établissements publics
territoriaux donc vous êtes dans une
sorte de territoire alors moi ça
s'appelle le pt12 vous avez le PT 11
personne ne sait qu'il est dans ce
territoire vous n'avez pas d'élection
directe donc les gens n'ont absolument
aucune conscience vraiment en fait ça ça
pose des problèmes c'est des échelons en
fait qui sont mis
intermédiaires et je trouve que c'est
des problèmes de démocratie et de
cohérence pour les pour les citoyens qui
sont quand même le nombre de communes
vous ne touchez pas ensuite
les départements tout ça se combinent
avec les grandes régions tout ça vous
semble cohérent ben nous les grandes
régions on n'est pas trop pour c'est ce
que je vous explique à l'instant mais en
fait la question c'est de pas faire des
juste des ajustements sur des choses à
un moment il faut qu'on revoit comment
et organiser le territoire et du coup la
démocratie aux différentes échelles et
comment elle se répondent et nous par
exemple dans l'idée de planification
écologique d'avoir de se rendre maître
du temps il y a l'idée d'avoir bon
quelque chose de planification avec des
objectifs nationaux qui sont donnés et
ensuite que par commune avec les
syndicats avec les associations et puis
s'il y avait un déclinaison de ce qu'on
peut faire à chacun des échelons et je
trouve qu'en terme de démocratie c'est
intéressant rapidement pour conclure sur
le cas de l'Alsace en fait on a notre
projet est un projet de simplification
et de proximité parce que les deux
Conseils départementaux ont été réunis à
deux ans donc il n'y a plus qu'une
collectivité européenne à l'échelle de
l'Alsace qui en fait elle est
compétences d'un département et donc
l'idée ça serait d'absorber les
compétences régionales et d'avoir une
collectivité unique à l'échelle de
l'Alsace qui a les fois les compétences
de la région et du département et donc
on fait sauter un strate une strate et
donc c'est de la simplification pour les
élus locaux qui travaillent au jour le
jour et puis surtout plus de proximité
pour les concitoyens travaux chantiers
merci beaucoup
portefeuille merci beaucoup vous restez
avec nous Vincent roux est avec nous en
direct du Fier en live pour une ultime
question d'actualité Vincent oui
à Strasbourg aujourd'hui entre autour
d'un certain nombre de pays qui refusent
de passer au véhicule électrique enfin à
tous les véhicules électriques à partir
de 2035 c'est une fronde menée par
l'Allemagne et l'Italie Bruno Le Maire
lui a dit que la France soutiendrait le
passage au tout électrique à partir de
2035 est-ce que vous sentiendrez le
ministre de l'économie dans cette dans
cette croisade Mathilde panot alors
première échelon de réponse évidemment
là où on soutient la position que la
France a pris c'est que il faut une
bifurcation
urgente de nos modes de déplacement et
de mobilité là où on est beaucoup plus
sceptique sur ce qui est dit est fait
c'est que je crois que nous n'avons pas
à faire à des problèmes individuels
notamment passer au toute électrique
pour nous ce n'est pas la solution
solution mais comment est-ce qu'on
affronte un problème collectif et
notamment comment est-ce qu'on remet à
la fois des transports en commun de
qualité et qui passent assez
régulièrement avec pourquoi pas la
gratuité de transport en commun qui
permet de les développer comment est-ce
qu'on remet vraiment de l'argent dans le
ferroviaire et dans le fret qui s'est
effondré dans notre pays et là nous ne
sommes pas du tout d'accord avec ce qui
a été fait dans ce quinquennat mais
aussi dans le quinquennat précédent et
d'ailleurs dans d'autres ou vraiment on
est très très loin de ce qu'il faudrait
faire donc évidemment nous la qualité de
l'air par exemple ça nous intéresse
évidemment mais si c'est au détriment de
gens qui n'auront pas les moyens de
pouvoir passer à l'électrique alors
c'est une écologie non populaire et nous
nous sommes les partisans de l'écologie
populaire et notamment qu'on mette des
moyens dans son propre Vincent et
justement pour tous ceux qui ont pas les
moyens de passer au tout électrique
justement et en particulier notamment
dans la dans la ruralité où c'est un
vrai problème aujourd'hui ou il y a une
vraie angoisse pour du passage du
thermique à l'électrique comment on fait
pour eux on les abandonne non les
abandonne pas on commence par remettre
des services publics généralement et
c'est ce que les gilets jaunes cessaient
de dire lorsqu'ils se mobilisait les
gilets jaunes ils se sont mobilisés
notamment parce qu'ils devaient prendre
la voiture pour absolument tout mais
aussi parce que vous avez une école
fermée dans chaque village
depuis de chaque jour depuis 10 ans vous
avez
des hôpitaux et des marternités qui sont
en train de fermer là je vois un nouveau
rapport qui dit qu'il faudrait de
nouveau fermer sans maternité ce qui est
une aberration incroyable donc remettre
des services publics avoir des mobilités
douces avoir évidemment des trains
réouvrir les petites lignes je rappelle
que dans le dernier budget nous avions
voté l'Assemblée nationale dans dans sa
majorité trois milliards d'euros pour le
ferroviaire et que avec le 49-3 c'est 3
milliards d'euros ont été purement et
simplement effacés donc oui il faut
remettre des moyens pour faire en sorte
que les gens ne soient pas constamment
obligé d'utiliser leur voiture merci
beaucoup Vincent allez on retourne à
l'Assemblée une seconde pour un épisode
évidemment qui a été marquant la semaine
dernière c'est le bras d'honneur vous
l'avez fait allusion tout à l'heure du
garde des sceaux à un député LR Olivier
Marleix qui venait d'évoquer et c'est
c'est poursuites judiciaire il a dit
qu'il faisait un bras d'honneur à la
présomption d'innocence qui venait
d'être piétiné et il s'est excusé d'une
façon assez solennelle et émue donc acte
écoutez imaginez si ça avait été un
insoumis qui avait fait ça ça serait pas
donc hâte d'ontact et on passe à autre
chose je dis juste il s'est excusé après
deux interruptions de séance après que y
compris des personnes de renaissance et
autres lui intime le fait qu'il devait
s'excuser parce que ce n'était pas
seulement le président Marley qui
l'insultait mais l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale et honnêtement
je trouve que pour des un gouvernement
qui ne cesse de faire l'arbitre des
élégances et de nous donner des leçons
de maintien à tout va c'est quand même
assez déplorable d'en arriver à des
choses comme ça ou quand vous regardez
la vidéo il n'y a non pas un non pas
deux mais trois bras d'honneur qui sont
fait à Olivier Marley est-ce que vous
vous pouvez dire ça présidente d'un
groupe ou des députés effectivement
aussi ont traité d'assassin par exemple
un ministre il s'est écrit et vous et
vous avez dit c'est bon c'est excusé
deux choses d'abord à quel point elle
était exceptionnel dans n'importe quel
démocratie le garde des sceaux aurait dû
démissionner c'est la première fois
qu'un garde des Sceaux est mise en
examen et continue dans sa fonction donc
il pointait quand même un
dysfonctionnement grave comment
expliquer vous que il soit toujours au
gouvernement alors c'est une question
qu'on peut poser
je ne sais pas demander à Emmanuel
Macron c'est lui qui décide de ça
puisque vous le savez le gouvernement
est choisi directement à la par la
première ministre par le président pour
la première ministre et ensuite par la
première ministre validé par le par le
président donc c'est une anomalie
démocratique que pointée Olivier marlex
et je pense que c'est une anomalie que
Eric Dupont-Moretti soit toujours au
gouvernement pour oui je pense que dans
n'importe quelle démocratie
effectivement elle aurait démissionné
merci beaucoup Mathilde sa fonction en
faisant cela il a déshonoré sa fonction
dit Mathilde panot en parlant d'Éric
Dupont-Moretti merci beaucoup d'avoir
été l'invité d'audition publique
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté tous les deux de débattre sur
deux sujets absolument majeurs et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine bien sûr à
19h30 sur SCP et public c'est la bonne
soirée
[Musique]